oh you can't believe where we are
tonight we're in Barbara's home this
place is a very secret penthouse I'm
trying to make it exciting Barbara but
we have a beautiful view of the park
we're in the kitchen because Barbara is
making me dinner tonight
which she owes me I ordered in sushi
takeout it's all you're worth but what's
the important thing about tonight is
Barbara's gonna help me on this
fantastic new episode of ask mr.
wonderful we have some incredible
questions Barbara has her own opinions I
don't agree with any of them you know
that from shark tank but it doesn't mean
she doesn't deserve a voice at the table
so that's we're gonna do a table well at
your table but before we start Barbara
we're gonna do a shout out for alpha M
remember I remember them you kicked his
ass you kicked his ass out of shark tank
twice but I didn't know who's gonna give
me free Sunwest nearly made a deal with
him but it didn't work out he's gone on
okay yeah really nice guy very
successful now these are enemy
sunglasses chuckling pay for this and
you're getting paid I want apart I'm not
putting on until I know if you're
getting paid I always get paid for
everything are you gonna give me a
portion
probably yeah oh forget it maybe I get
some free glasses out of it anyways
Barbara put the glasses on help out I'm
out
you screw them once you're gonna screw a
third time with your alpha M enemy
glasses mister actually lovely
everything looks great look below for
that connection directly to alpha M
sight and get a great deal 20% off I
can't believe I'm camping for you yeah
wonderful 20 is a 20% discount off these
amazing Lassie Barbara stop your whining
I can't believe it what happened oh by
the way these are our action figures you
ever seen these puppies
this is mr. wonderful and this is me
sitting on his lap Barbara's comes in a
little broom mystery come on our thing
is really cute yeah like did you want to
answer some questions tonight Barbara
yes I do I want to ask some questions
yes I do
are you ready Barbara yeah I am I am
okay here we go
we're gonna get into the questions right
now let me just get us friar
they're from all around the world that's
what's so interesting about it let's
just listen to them and then I'll let
you decide what you want to do and if
you want to contribute I hope you will
but you're gonna find these really
intriguing so let's start with number
one here hey Kevin my name is James and
I was wondering what you think the best
way to spend a life is thank you James
now you're talking Big Boy how to spend
a life why bro big question I think he's
come to the right place why does the
answer that but I think if you want to
have a great life you should give all
the satisfaction life if you think back
and anything you've done is in the act
of giving so if you're not gonna be a
giver you're gonna have maybe as more
successful life by a lot of people's
standards but you're not gonna have the
wonderful satisfaction when you go to
bed at night that you really have led a
wonderful life but giving to whom to
whoever you are I'm not talking about
charity giving I'm not talking about
making sure that your husband your
significant other well I'm a good on a
good day with my husband but what I am
singing about is being a good friend
being a good parent taking the time to
be kind all these things accumulate into
a feeling of self-worth that makes you
feel as though you've left or you've
lived a very good life that's what I
think that's why very profound I must
admit I'm gonna answer it slightly
differently I'm sure you have to find
something that you love to do that
really keeps you engaged if you want a
great successful life I'm including
family and everything else but it's the
work you do that gets you up in the
morning I don't work for money anymore
Barbara worships you it's not what its
gonna give you the satisfaction when
you're old and gray and looking back at
where you spent your time and how well
you spent it I got a belief I loved
working you know when I pass on to
wherever I'm going up there or down
there I'm gonna go right back to work
when I arrive and the other thing I'm
doing I told my son this all my watches
are being buried with me because I mean
you go to perpetuity you need to tell
the time all the time oh my god leave
those two photos I always say this
they're gonna be buried with me and what
are we wearing today Barbara this is an
FP joy
oh it's you love it I love it kind of it
feel like a red watch yeah stop your
whining let's get another question here
here we go this is gonna be interesting
hello mr. wonderful my name is Christian
I'm in my early 30s and against all odds
made a career as a classical musician I
teach music as a professor at the
University and perform and travel
actively I'm very happy but in order to
support my parents and my own family in
the future it would be great to maximize
income my question is what's advisable
for someone who has a career but would
like to simply make more money should I
just focus on my current career and
invest conservatively or is it advisable
or even possible to pursue business
ideas while having a completely
different career path you're my favorite
shark we all know he sounds like
Beethoven yes he does and so he brings
up a really interesting issue he's
clearly a classically trained musician
making a living as a classically trained
musician which is impossible but he
wants even more cash Barbara what do you
tell Beethoven I would say stay with
what you're doing and invest in things
conservatively he has gotten life by the
tail of having something he loves to do
and don't mess with it that would be my
advice but if he wants to take some of
his income and put it to work somewhere
what do you think he needs to find a
good person to invest for him because if
he's going to be distracted from his
work he's gonna be more stressed over
how it's doing I think he's gotta learn
to trust someone and delegated
interesting I was going to say that's a
remarkable career to be successful in
and I think you can build it even bigger
if you stay focused I would kind of
agree with you if you're good at that
don't agree we're not used to I'm not
used to it either maybe I have to throw
you out the window now
but the point is he should stay focused
and put his other endeavors behind his
true love which is music he's such a
lucky man he has that kind of I really
like that he'll be told
and I love this or a great one let's go
aren't these fun barber hello mr.
wonderful this is Alejandro Franco from
Colombia I'm graduating from University
in one year and I am building three
businesses on the side but I'm having a
hard time finding a mentor or somebody I
can shadow and learn from that is
actually successful in business so my
question is how can a 22 year old make
himself useful or stand out to a
business person that can perhaps take a
risk to pull me along and teach me what
are the skills and things you would need
to see in a candidate to even consider
teaching him I am willing to go and find
a mentor no matter how hard so thank you
for your answer he's having a hard time
finding a mentor what do you say 22 year
olds it's got so much ambition Barbara
really sure showed you the way it was a
one mentor that pointed left or right
and you found your way I doubt it
no the life of hard knocks pushed me all
over the place so what he's looking to
someone else for an answer bad idea all
your answers have to do with yourself
what you experience what you expose
yourself to how much you play in the
traffic what you reject what you accept
you have to find your own path in life
this guy's looking for someone else with
the answer like I'll follow you know
we're called individuals for a reason
everybody's an individual he's got to
find his own gig you get help from
friends you help from more senior people
in your field but in the end you have to
find your own way I really believe that
I think the kids off to a good start
though he sounds like he's got his stuff
together I like the international aspect
he doesn't believe he's got his stuff
together well because he's looking for
the answer so if he tries any one of
these businesses he's got multiple
opportunities go make something happen
he'll learn pretty quickly how damn hard
yourself
yeah of course I'm okay with that answer
maybe I won't throw you out the window
on Shark Tank
all of our good entrepreneurs never
really listen to us they listen but they
don't follow our advice they find their
own advice and that's the Marcus well
they listen when we won't give them a
deal because their valuations are too
high
all right next we're really ripping
through them here Barbara I'm impressed
with you yeah here we go ready
hey mr. wonderful my name is Antoine I'm
21 years old I'm currently playing
professional baseball in the minor
leagues my question to you is if you are
someone who didn't have the luxury of
being available 24/7 and using the money
that you have in a bank account to start
up the business but you still wanted to
find out ways how you could invest or
utilize the money that you do have in
your bank account how would you go about
that for this example let's say you have
a hundred thousand dollars in your bank
account how would you go about using
that hundred thousand dollars and
getting it to work for you or what would
you do with this thank you so he sounds
like he really has a hundred thousand
because if he's in the juniors he's
obviously got it together as a baseball
player kind of unique because that
career can end like that it's a little
injury you're done but he could take a
page out of Alex Rodriguez which is
which is Alex went to every smart guy he
knew once he became a major league
player and he asked how do I make money
what can you teach me about your
business that will help me make money so
then when he retired from baseball
he actually had circle of friends that
he could lean on he invested in real
estate like crazy he invested in
municipal bonds like crazy but he knew
what he was doing because he was willing
to be a student while he was a
professional baseball player I think
that so he stayed focused on where his
cash was coming from which because this
kids young and has a lot of dough but
he's curious yeah asking questions he's
a smart kid he's fine because he's
asking early yeah so the key is if
you're professional athlete don't get an
entourage don't have all these
hanger-ons they're taking will do though
it's terrible to do that such a waste of
money the only entreprise should have is
your mother that's it your mother oh
your mother's something everybody else
tell them to go beep because you're
working hard to make that money and
you're in a very risky career you can
buy your mother car house etcetera etc
but nobody else that's good advice
alright here we go yeah even even the
girls forget like come on so you get
serious with somebody all right here we
go
hey mr. wonderful so I know you're
always talking about going to college
for engineering because you do the safe
that's the safest route but what do you
think about IT and cyber security cyber
security is what he's talking about in
electrical property and cybersecurity
well I would say we have somebody we
know in Shark Tank that's very involved
in doing quite well in cybersecurity
Robert Herjavec so he's done very well
with it you know I've taught him so much
over the years I'm just thinking he's
got engineering and cybersecurity I
would say those are just the right
column check a box on know find what you
love and you'll do very well but if
you've already spent the energy and the
discipline to go through engineering
which is give it a shake he must love
engineering so I think combining you
know cybersecurity the engineer is
pretty smart if you ask me so Barbara
wants you to just get out start making
some money meet a girl that's what you
said all right here we go next on the
hit parade hi Kevin I've been investing
in single-family and duplex real estate
for the past two years in which I have
bought four properties with my own money
I often find myself coming across deals
with 20 to 25 percent yearly are wise
and great cash flows but I've run out of
money to buy them myself and I want to
accelerate I'm only 26 so all my friends
are young broke and owned nothing my
family is typically conservative with
their money and are skeptical of what
I'm doing even though I'm doing pretty
well so can you give me any better ideas
on where to find the money to fund my
deals thanks Barbara this is all about
you you're the real estate Queen let me
tell you something that you have you
have the knowledge and the expertise to
spot a good deal analyze it and make it
happen that's worth a fortune
the great thing about that is you've got
the time to really do it you're young
you're eager you're gonna learn it very
well and the people that have the money
don't have the time to learn it so you
have a perfect situation where you can
get
I'm talking the computer issue with you
know I was wondering about that Barbara
so look into computer cutis confuse her
you're right is it check the camera
Barbara he's watching you right now and
you think so Barbara is really what is
he of course he is even it's all things
you're not supposed listen I'm invested
in real estate all over the New York
City area and I got in there early and
made a fortune but I liked one thing I
like time because I was running a
business and building a business and
building equity and I didn't have an
inch to spare so I found myself guys
like you and gals like you all over the
area and asked him to locate property
for me and tell me where I should invest
I became the money person they became
the talent person on locating it so what
you could do easily is find people to
invest along with you create a fund or
at least a partnership and get going
it's the easiest way to do it because
you have what they don't have you have
time and expertise and they have what
you don't have which is money so it's a
natural partnership just get out there
and start telling people what you're
doing what your chance returns have been
on these dual family homes and convince
them easily through your record that
they should be investing more in zyk and
your assumptions or your suggestion to
him is that he gets a fee for doing this
because basically he's doing all the
work to find the places really you would
be the general partner you can get a
management fee but those details are
less important than the fact that you
build a friendship and a trust
relationship with someone with a lot of
cash once you have them in your pocket
and they really trust you you can do
whatever you want in life and you could
bring other people along with you
believe it I'm agreeing with Barbara I
can't believe it I never do that I'm
having I'm having a Justin I'm sure look
look that's good advice I totally agree
the guy needs cash he is proven that he
can make what sound solid I want to
invest you sounds solid as a rock to my
ear very interesting anyways congrats
getting Barbara to endorse your deal I
can't believe it yeah I should be
getting a royalty for that oh sure hi
mr. wonderful my name is Elizabeth I am
a hustler slash entrepreneur and a
military wife and my question for you
today is how in this crazy world
Philip so many talented entrepreneurs
can I get in front of you guys on Shark
Tank I have such an amazing story to
tell with being a special-operations
wife my story is so different from your
normal military wives and how I've built
this business to be successful while my
husband is deployed I was loved
opportunity and just any insight you
have into getting in front of you guys
would be so appreciated thank you you
know what I'm thinking about Mindy
casting absolutely all the roles go
through Mindy casting right you should
send you a pitch deck to both mr.
wonderful and myself though we can't
look at the fields first that's a bit
sale we sent it to Mindy Cassie and
shield she's guaranteed to because she
sounded so compelling on that question I
want to we'll both we'll both help you
do that so you're gonna have to figure
out how to get that pitch so give her
your email address come on right now I
can't do that to like a million people
now I won't you guys get to use words
you don't mean it
that's a bargain calm send me your pitch
deck Wow look at it I'll send it to
Mindy at Mindy can't send everything
else too Barbara Corcoran comm I need
everything everything you watch us send
it there I love this Barbie just that's
fantastic you may want to think about
this you have a couple of things going
for you your military shark tank loves
military people you're articulate Shark
Tank TV loves I have a vision of her in
my mind and the idea that you're a
hustler that's what is the fruit of
shark tank that's what makes that engine
run so come on come on send me a [ __ ]
I'll make sure they get it
listen I think that's terrific look
another fantastic episode of ask mr.
wonderful with a special guest tonight
in her home you know the truth is nobody
gets to ever come to this home because
she's so green I invite everybody you
know barb is over here just a Camry
anyway I've been talking to the wrong
screen there's three cameras here we got
this one here that's kind of looking up
and seeing this well let me just look at
the size of your listeners right of the
record everybody's invited at this home
I've avoided mr. wonderful form
two years right he got word that
everybody was invited about him so he
decided this is absolutely fantastic see
who's coming you just walked right in
the reason I'm here is to check it out I
may buy it I really like this i daddy
it's so cheap you never pay with this
brace but I do like this place Barbara I
like the view I'm sure it's a gorgeous
view and everything is wonderful about
my own but this is the wrong way you're
gonna put your belly to the barn page
I'll give you 800 thousand Oh what a
deal anyways thanks for coming everybody
and now we've got to get to work Barbara
oh look at the sushi did you make that
yourself
oh that's wonderful oh one more thing
one more thing one more thing Barbara
she wanted me this embarrassing no this
is cold hard merch calm this is for
Nancy and Kirsten so they can eat if
they sell any of these they get a little
bit of it that's okay and look at this
one this is know it Barbara you look
great in there check this out I'm not
wearing this crap it says get money and
get free that's Barbara this this merch
is smoking
these are 29.95 sale Oh hard merch calm
oh yeah baby
what I like about this it's terrific
[Laughter]
alright everybody thank you for coming
we'll be back next week not here
[Laughter]